what do we do with this configuration
what's unprotected this guy no he's not
night has on mmm lights in the corner
sad story for this night oh man what a
tough one I'd like this to start as well
I think ah yeah copycat game copycat
variation now what
mmm
alright
well what do you do here what do you do
throw your night here call it a day pawn
here so the bishop can see the world
night here so you obstruct this pawn
which isn't really a great thing ah man
these nights are tough to get working um
oh man this is tough to play well I
don't think moving this prawn one or two
squares is any good so I might as well
throw it in there on b6 all right now
maybe night e 72 c 6 he's kind of stupid
here although although no no just a baby
step now maybe I could get in d5
probably not cuz why to play a 4 and
then they'll be chopped no no no no I
lied I could still be all right because
if he's taken i can just recapture
connected nights ah now i'm gonna play
this move probably have that as a
response it's going to get violent let's
try
let's give it a whirl hmm
well you know if there is a drawback
with this move that I just played it's
that the position is opening up and I
believe why is better positioned to deal
with the opening up of the position or
maybe not the move I was most fearful of
was D for now I could take here i'm on
the Queen I'm assuming this okay because
what else is there now I guess I'm
taking and I better quickly get in a
position where I can Castle Queen side
and I am in a position just as white is
to Castle Queen side but should I Castle
Queen side is a question that I'm not so
sure I have an answer to ah this night
is probably a bit too scary I could go
here and then Castle kingside but my
queen looks like a big idiot stuck in
the corner so I'd like to get my queen
out before I Castle kingside but then
I'm questioning the time that it would
take to do that one two three and only
then I'm in a position to Castle I don't
know I think that's starting to become a
bit far-fetched
hmm cuz i think in the meantime this
will be played oh i just don't know
well maybe I could deal with this night
putting pressure on this pawn do this
then maybe I could take it out with my
bishop at some point let's give it a
shot all right next up I got to get my
queen working she's foolish in the
corner foolish Queen in the corner let's
go clean
right now what let's just take why not
what a solid game here let's go queen I
don't know what to do to make
improvements um I should really watch
out about this pond push maybe and wipe
now they're not going to do that anyhow
it's close to being able to control a
square that's deep in my position
um now what
two minutes 30 seconds not a lot
I don't know what to even suggest here
really tongue-tied because I don't know
we both have our pieces out there's a
structural defect here ok so what may be
my night could land on this square one
day ok trying to take my night out there
that's oh I probably shouldn't have done
that oh I should have thought more about
that 100 big trouble no I have a
solution to it fortunately I thought
night here was going to kill me but I
would have something like night c4 ok
I'm on this pond gotta watch out for
this tender square it's being hit right
now coming under heavy fire should I be
afraid I have a defense this night is a
bit off sides now this pond is still hit
if there's a sack on this crack it come
over there's not really anything
happening here also my queen has lateral
defense of this so there's not like a
knight move this this pun is uh it has
full strength it's not just shielding
the Queen from getting here because I
have that support so i could capture in
that direction now i believe i could
take here and get away with it or can I
I probably can't take here night here I
think it starts become overwhelming to
defend this pond so what do you do when
it's overwhelming you get rid of a pest
and right now that pest is this night
even though he's on the edge what a pain
get rid of the pain
okay now what Wow
okay well you know what I'm gonna play
my night here I got to watch over this
square if a night is able to stick
around in this square for any length of
time what that implies is that e 6 is a
lot closer to having a white piece land
there
alright my bishop does best to run home
run home bishop you have no other square
that's good actually I could have played
here yeah add another option but I think
this is still fine it is watching over
this pun and let's go here I'm not sure
why oh I'm hitting a pond tied game I'm
not gonna be able to offer much after
this game I can feel it yupper okay wait
let's give a check and grab a pond um
I'm gonna take the pun no not here no I
have a cup of my bishop okay now yeah I
have this cover my bishop haha ah
sneakiness if my bishop wasn't there
that'd be a good move because of forks
if I took then my rook is hanging wow
it's game over could do this but it's
not getting complicated here give a
check the king is running out time's up
good game interesting setup we had to
work with them that one huh Fisher
random all right yeah i don't know i
think my opponent did good with the
moves again I try and make sure well
forget make sure like when I'm a cap on
move I'm trying to have it to more than
one thing
so I'm like oh i don't know like help
the bishop out and also maybe prevent
like particular night moves and stuff
like that I usually I try to make it
have make it half make it do more than
one thing so anyhow I think we're both
pretty equal right here with regard to
our development and I don't know I'd be
curious to see what a computer be saying
about this position I think it's pretty
balanced and we both did a pretty decent
to get our pieces all working I don't
know good game only the only mistakes
happen real mistakes happen when there
was a time issue but other than that
really good game